vamos a multiplicar 1.21 un 10 con 21
centésimas por cuarenta y tres milésimos
10 puntos 0.43 y los invito a que
ustedes pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten
por su cuenta
pero vamos a hacer algo vamos a hacer un
ejercicio con algo algo más simplificado
vamos a multiplicar 121
x
que son básicamente los mismos números
solo que estos no tienen el punto
decimal
y dado que estos no tienen punto decimal
esto ya lo sabemos hacer vamos a hacer
la multiplicación primero de 121 por 43
y tomaremos las unidades tomaremos este
3 y multiplicaremos 3 por 1 es igual a 3
3 por 2 es igual a 6 3 por 1 es igual a
y ahora nos vamos a la columna de las
decenas donde este 4 nos representa
realmente un 40 como nos vamos al número
de las decenas colocaremos en las
unidades un cero y tendremos 40 por 140
40 por 20 840 por 100 4.000 y entonces
podremos hacer la suma
sumaremos entonces estos números y
pondremos con un color distinto la suma
de ellos 30 es igual a 36 4 es igual a
10 llevaremos 113 más 8 es igual a 12
14 es igual a 5 por lo tanto la
multiplicación de 121 por 43 nos dará
exactamente 5.203 ahora como es que
vamos de este producto al producto de
este número pues para que nosotros
lleguemos de 1.21 a 121 lo que estamos
haciendo es multiplicar este número
100 estamos recorriendo dos posiciones
el punto decimal ya que multiplicamos
por 100 1.21 por cien será igual a 121
si nosotros estamos buscando ir de 43
milésimos a 43 unidades lo que estamos
haciendo es multiplicar por mil
estamos recorriendo tres posiciones
el punto decimal para qué entonces
lleguemos a 43 unidades para que
nosotros vayamos de este producto a este
producto bueno de hecho a este producto
lo que hemos hecho es multiplicar por
100 y por 1000 es decir por 100.000 así
es que para que nosotros regresemos de
este producto hacia este producto lo que
vamos a hacer es dividir
ahora vamos en sentido contrario y
dividiremos este producto entre 100
y también lo dividiremos entre 1000
o podemos decir que estamos dividiendo
entre 100.000 vamos a reescribir este
número aquí escribimos entonces 5000
3 y ahora imaginemos que el punto
decimal se encuentra aquí primero
dividiremos entre 100 estamos dividiendo
entre 10 entre 100 y luego dividiremos
entre 1000
/ 10 / 100 / mil
el punto decimal estará aquí y con eso
tenemos nuestra respuesta 1.21 por 0
puntos 0 43 será igual a punto 0 5 2 0 3
así es que una manera en la que podemos
pensarlo es simplemente multiplica estos
dos números como si no hubiese un punto
decimal ahí y después cuenta cuántos
números o cuántas posiciones hay a la
derecha del punto decimal si nosotros
hacemos eso podemos ver que aquí hay 1
y cinco números que están a la derecha
del punto decimal y por lo tanto en el
producto deberíamos de tener 1 2 3 4 5
números a la derecha del punto decimal
vamos a ponerlo aquí cuáles son
la cantidad de números a la derecha del
punto decimal y de dónde sale esto
recuerda que cuando nosotros
transportamos y multiplicamos esto para
eliminar los puntos decimales
multiplicamos por 100.000 ahora este
producto lo estamos dividiendo entre 100
mil
cuando nosotros multiplicamos por
100.000 básicamente lo que hicimos fue
recorrer el punto decimal cinco veces a
la derecha ahora al dividir estaremos
recorriendo cinco lugares a la izquierda
el punto decimal que realmente
representa dividir entre 10 dividido
entre 100 entre 1000 entre 10.000 entre
100.000 que fue la división que tuvimos
aquí con esto tendríamos nuestra
respuesta final